foreign
[Music]
okay looks like we are live everywhere
so hello Instagram hello Tech talk hello
everywhere else we're just going to give
it a minute or two for uh to leave some
time for people to join but thanks very
much looking forward to taking live
questions about the infinite mindset how
to live an infinite mindset I'm here
with my colleague Devin hi Devon hello
um and uh she's going to feed me
questions that are coming in from you
um so thank you to everyone coming in I
can oh I love seeing all the countries
why don't you shout out where you're
from so I can tell hello from Tulsa uh
hello from New York uh tell me where
you're from Telly where are you from
Boston Germany Netherlands Brazil
Michigan I love this this always blows
me away Netherlands Morocco Copenhagen
Miami
New Jersey exotic New Jersey
Florida New Zealand Australia man some
of you be sleeping Malaysia Denmark I
love this it's so fantastic Columbia
Chicago Dallas Portugal oh my God it's
flying in hello everyone from around the
world this is so fantastic thanks for
joining
um as many of you know I've been uh
practicing living my life building my
business with an infinite mindset
um and so I thought we'd take a little
time to answer your questions live here
on all the platforms uh why don't we
jump in Devin so you can post your
questions hopefully I'll see them but
Devin's more likely to get them hello
from Iraq hello Oxford hello Brazil
hello London hello Ohio hello Hong Kong
Dubai Islamabad freaking love this
um okay
Devin first question yes we have
Jennifer from Facebook who is asking the
most simple question of what is the
infinite game okay Jennifer from
Facebook asking the correct question to
get started which is what is the
infinite game glad you asked Jennifer
um so in the mid 1980s a philosopher and
theologian by the name of Dr James cars
Define these two types of games finite
games and infinite games a finite game
is defined as known players fixed rules
and an agreed upon objective uh football
for example if there's a winner
necessarily there has to be a loser but
more important in a finite game there's
always a beginning a middle and an end
right then you have infinite games
infinite games are defined as known and
unknown players which means you don't
necessarily know who all the players are
and any player can join the game
whenever they want the rules are
changeable which means every player can
play however they want want and the
objective is to is to perpetuate the
game to stay in the game as long as
possible turns out we are players in
infinite games every day of Our Lives
whether we know it or not uh for example
uh you will never be number one in your
marriage you can be number two but you
can't be number one
um uh you there's no such thing as
winning education you can come in first
for the finite amount of time we're at
school where we agree upon the time
frames and the metrics but nobody wins
learning or wins education there's no
such thing as the winner of careers and
there's definitely no such thing as
winning business
but if we listen to the language of so
many leaders it becomes abundantly clear
that they don't know the game they're
playing in they talk about being number
one being the best or beating their
competition
based on what based on one upon what
agreed upon metrics time frames and
objectives and this is a problem because
when we play with a finite mindset in an
infinite game when we play to win in a
game that has no Finish Line there are
some very predictable and consistent
outcomes the big ones being the decline
of trust the decline of cooperation and
the decline of innovation if a company
goes bankrupt the other companies don't
win anything they have to just keep
playing and new companies can start and
join at any time these are infinite
games and if you look a lot of the
challenges that we're facing in our
world both in business and in politics
are because too many of our leaders are
playing with the wrong mindset for the
game that they are in
thanks for asking Jennifer that's the
finite game in the infinite game and
I've been practicing living my life and
building my business with an infinite
mindset
um okay Devin next question yeah quickly
so this is from Russia on Instagram and
she was wondering what would you say to
kids to keep them focused on living a
life with no Finish Line oh I love this
one
um from Finland was it no from Instagram
oh from Instagram sorry Instagram from
Finland same thing
um uh she asked what do you do to teach
kids about the infinite game to teach
kids okay so there's a great story that
really captures what it means to live in
with an infinite mindset it's a it's a
Chinese story it's told many different
ways this is the way that I know it
there's a young man born with a
remarkable natural ability for horse
riding and everyone in the village says
you're so lucky and the monk says we'll
see
and then one day he has an accident and
falls off his horse and breaks his leg
and ruins ends his career and everyone
in the village says you're so unlucky
and the monk says we'll see
and then uh War breaks out and all the
young men are sent into battle but he
can't go because of his busted leg and
everyone in the village says you're so
lucky and the monk says we'll see and
the point is good news bad news who
knows
um the point is is that life is life
continues and everything bad that
happens to us will end and everything
good that happens to us will end
um as Maya Angelou said every storm
eventually Runs Out of Rain
um and so the point is is everything is
temporary so we can't get too high and
mighty about our successes that keeps us
humble but also everything bad that
happens to us
um will pass and sometimes sometimes
prove to be great lessons I can tell you
some of the greatest struggles I've had
in my life I never want to repeat them
but I'm glad they're happened I'm glad
they happened and this is why I think
learning to sit in discomfort is
actually a really important thing
um but teaching kids about that little
Chinese proverb I think is uh is really
really really helpful okay who else do
we have
Nintendo's cute very cute Nintendo's
ah great question how do I see the
overnight boom of A.I uh affecting the
infinite game
um so so
if we're using it depends how we're
using it right which is I think
um very often when machine learning
comes into something actually let's
think this through this one's a hard one
that's a good question it's called stump
Simon
um the question is does it have an
impact at all maybe that's where I'm
going like I'm trying to think so AI if
AI is used for constant Improvement so
if we plug it into a system so that's
constantly finding errors and mistakes
that we can constantly constantly
improve something and never feel that
the work is done then I really like it
and I think AI is valuable when we use
AI to try to win uh to figure out
formulas even though there's no such
thing as winning then I think it only
exaggerates all the ills of uh a finite
mindset
um so I guess the answer is it depends
it's kind of like money which is like is
money good or bad well it depends how
you use it it depends what you're doing
with it it's like rank or power is power
and rank good or bad well it depends
what you're doing once you achieve it so
I think it's the application of the AI
that I'm more uh nervous of and I think
it's important that we know about these
two different games so that we apply it
in the right way so for example if you
look at politics
um of
um which is an election is clearly a
finite game there was a winner there's a
loser there's a beginning middle and end
and we agree upon what the metrics are
but once somebody is elected to office
they have to change their mindset into
an infinite mindset to be one of
governance and the problem is when
politicians are constantly playing to
win after they've already been elected
because they're they're as if they're in
the next election already and that's
where we get
um poor governance which is they think
they're running for election and they're
not at least not yet
um so yeah that's a good question about
the AI I like that one
all right the next one is from uh Sandra
on Instagram she asked what other
companies have you noticed that have an
infinite mindset since your book was
found so the question was what other
companies have I noticed are playing
with an infinite mindset since the book
was published some companies have
actually been pretty public about this
um Brian chesky over at Airbnb has
publicly said
um he wants to build an infinite company
and be more infinite minded
um so I I love that um I've had
conversations with some folks at Nike
who said that they're trying to be more
infinite minded Walmart is trying to be
more infinite minded I think what's
happening is a lot of leaders that are
coming in are recognizing that some of
those uh leaders that came before them
were so excessively finite minded that
they've actually done damage to the
companies that they now lead and they
have to change their mindsets to
actually put their companies back on a
longer path
um but the the I'm very proud that that
that that that little idea that Dr cars
originated and that I've been able to
build upon it's really finding it's it's
finding its momentum it's becoming more
and more of a thing which is great
because I believe in it um very very few
ideas are truths you know they're
usually opinions or points of view but
what Dr cars articulated truly is a
truth and uh it's my honor to build on
what he started so yes
there are more companies that seem to be
embracing there's no such thing as
perfect it's a constant struggle every
day but it is a mindset so for example
one of the things is to stop viewing the
competitors as competitors to be beaten
and start viewing them as Rivals to be
compared to in other words there are
other people who do what you do
sometimes they do what you do or
something's better than you what can you
learn from them so that you can
constantly improve if you're trying to
beat your competitors let me give it
another way so I was watching the
Olympics right
I was watching the ice skating and the
person who won the gold medal fell in
their routine well how can you win a
gold medal how can you be considered the
best ice skater in the world if you fell
in your routine I'll tell you because
the person who came silver fell twice so
they're not the best ice skater in the
world they're the best in that moment
against those competitors that's it
um and and very often we think of
business like an event where we think
we're the best because we ended the year
where we have you know more profit or
bigger market share except business is
not an ice skating competition because
it never ever ever ends uh more
important in business multiple companies
who sell about the same product about
the same price about the same quality
can all be wildly successful
simultaneously there is no winner so if
you're trying to beat your competition
in a in a in a game that has no ending
you get to pick the standards of what
winning looks like literally you can
choose the metrics
um all of a sudden I have a that was
funny
um uh um
then it doesn't go well so yes more
companies are embracing that thinking
which I really really love
nice Scott s from Facebook asked how is
the just cause different from company
values should we have both and if so how
do we best communicate each great
question uh what Scott
asks how how is the how is it just cause
different from company values
um so company values
um which should be immutable are um are
the mechanisms we use to help us manage
our culture to advance our just cause so
a just cause is a vision of the future a
just cause is a is a vision of the
future so just that we would be willing
to sacrifice our interests in order to
advance towards that cause it is an
ideal we'll never actually get there our
values are the are the are the edges on
the sandbox to help guide our Behavior
so for example one of the things that
gets companies in trouble is when they
believe that growth at all costs right
so we're so driven by growth that we
will take quality out of our products
put cheap ingredients in which could be
Health uh affect people's Health to
because we increase our margins we will
um we will lay people off needlessly to
increase uh to to to make our our Ledger
look better
etc etc this is growth at all costs
our values manages that all cost part so
we want to achieve our vision but not at
all costs the the the ends uh the me the
ends don't justify the means they both
have to be honorable
um so yeah values are the edges on the
sandbox we use to help us Advance
towards our cause and it's those values
that help us hire and work with people
to know that we we can get along and
trust each other if we had no values
then everything every relationship
becomes more transactional
values good
think about it we're not just friends
with people because they can get us into
a party right or get us into a club
we're friends with people because we
trust them and get along with them same
thing it's because they're shared values
it's not just because they can give us
something
um we're gonna have lots of
transactional relationships in our lives
but anything that involves Trust
um values matter for example if you go
buy a cup of coffee it's a transaction
we don't need deep trust with the
Barista
um
so there's plenty of transactions you
don't want all the relationships to be
like that
um Tick Tock keeps putting a hat and
mustache on me and I don't know why I
don't know if I turn that on if somebody
else turned that on but I'm getting a
kick out of it every time I look at my
phone I um I either have a banana on my
head or a sombrero
um okay next question
ah cowboy hat and mustache did I do that
I don't know
who was it oh
hello Aldrin Aldrin wants to know uh
what do I what was I say to somebody who
wants to join in my just cause
um thank you
um well let's articulate what my just
cause is I believe in a world I imagine
a world so you can always tell a good
just cause when you hear about
imagination something about the future
right I imagine a world
in which the vast majority of people
wake up every single morning inspired
feel safe wherever they are and end the
day fulfilled by the work that they do I
am fully aware that for us to actually
build that world it's going to take an
army of us it's going to take millions
of us because we have to undo some of
the practices from the past and change
the way we're building our company
companies change the way in which we're
leading our governments change the way
in which we're treating each other and
so the best thing you can do is be the
leader you wish you had the best thing
you can do is Embrace some of the ideas
that I've talked about and start with
why or Leaders Eat Last or the infinite
game in other words we need
practitioners I recognize that I stand
with my megaphone I have my bully pulpit
where I talk about what the future could
look like and I try and share as many of
the ideas as possible that will help us
get there but it's just talk as Thomas
Edison said Vision Without execution is
hallucination and so I need you Alden I
need you Aldrin
I need you to do the things if you work
with a small team I need you to be that
great leader so that it has ripples
we need to take care of each other and
change the way things were done in the
past so the best thing you can do to be
a part of the the movement is to is to
be a physical example of of the stuff
that I get to talk about and write about
thanks for asking and welcome to the
Army glad to March shoulder to shoulder
with you
I have a tiara now
on tick tock tick tock
hi Tick Tock yeah
all right but what can I do if they
don't listen ah I love this question I
get this question a lot so I work for a
family business how do I convince my
family business to know their why but
they won't listen Okay I get this
question all the time how do I get my
boss's boss's boss's boss to listen to
the stuff that we talk about and we
agree upon and the answer is you don't
um uh so the answer is you don't
unfortunately
um
um we cannot control or influence people
um oh sorry what did I do there I'm
making a mistake here
can you fix that
hi sorry I'm making a mess over here hi
good to see you sorry to sorry all right
anyway
um what was I talking about oh uh how do
you influence people that you have no
influence over the answer is you don't
we can only take responsibility for
ourselves
um and so we have to be the leaders we
wish we had no number of anonymously
sent books to our boss we'll change the
way that they lead unfortunately what
does change is that we become the
examples that um and when we lead the
way that we think leadership should
happen that we're the ones that put
forward vision for our teams what you
find is that morale is higher
performance is higher and any
open-minded senior leaders will look
down and say what are you doing and then
we can tell them but we've got the case
first or if they continue to ignore us
it's okay because we're building great
teams that will eventually get promoted
out or move to other companies and take
all the lessons that they learn from us
then eventually get promoted or move
away and then take the lessons and it's
the Ripple and this is very much a part
of the infinite mindset which is
accepting and learning that we may not
see results in the short term but if we
keep acting true to our values if we
keep acting uh um never mind if we keep
acting true to our values uh if we keep
acting towards our vision that
eventually eventually it starts to
Ripple I mean look at the ripples that
we form just by us everyone showing up
here today with common cause right look
at the ripples that we've created
because that we're all here marching
shoulder to shoulder believing in this
different vision of the world that we
all imagine this is what I mean so the
best thing we can do is uh is do it okay
what else we got
so
um Federico from LinkedIn would like to
know how do we teach infinite mindset to
generation C how do we teach an infinite
mindset Federico asks how do we teach an
infinite mindset to gen Z well frankly
we need to be teaching it to every
generation and uh frankly at some of the
older Generations yeah some of it's some
of the older Generations that are that
struggle the most it's it's the Boomers
that are the most finite minded because
that's the Jack Welch Generation
Um but I digress
um um the way we teach it is the way we
teach anything which is we talk about it
we talk about it we talk about it
um read my book read Dr Carson's book
talk about it yourself the great thing
about finite infinite games is you can
tell that little Chinese proverb you can
you can uh share the definition you
don't need me or my work to share these
ideas they're so simple understandable
and repeatable
um um and so I think we need to also
build it into our schools I think too
many schools are finite minded
um so uh
yeah I do think we need to teach it in
schools quite frankly
um I think you know we teach Math and
Science but we don't teach mindset we
don't teach
um how to manage stress we don't teach
how to view the world
um I think we need all of that in our
curricula if you ask me
um all right
the next question is
um from YouTube what if you are flat out
not a leader and just part of the game
um YouTube asks um what if you were flat
out not a leader and just part of the
game
um
well I mean leadership that's fine uh I
mean I don't really I'm I I think I
understand oh thank you very much I
think I understand the question I mean
every one of us it's kind of uh relative
um every one of us is a is a leader and
a follower right the best leaders are
the best followers
um no matter how senior they get they
still believe that they're in service to
something even bigger the pope for
example is in service to something even
bigger than himself right so believe it
or not the best leaders are the best
followers
um and if you're just part of the gang
then then that's okay but if you're the
one who says I'm going to take care of
the people in my gang if I'm going to
take care of the people on my team don't
look now but you're a leader
um but if you truly
um don't want that responsibility and
you don't have to have it leadership
comes with sacrifice
um then be a good follower which means
when the leader makes a decision work
hard to see that the leader's decision
is successful
um work hard to see that your teammates
have the resources they need you know
work hard to be a good team member
um I think good followership is
something we need to talk more about
quite frankly good followership
um looks a lot like good leadership
which is care about the person to the
left and care about to the person to the
right
um but we're not asking everybody to to
step up into rank or position but you do
get you do you do have to be a good team
member you do have to be a good teammate
um there's something really funny about
human dynamics and I learned this when I
went out to the Marine Corps I went out
to Paris Island to see how they make
Marines
and something really weird happens in
the first two weeks of boot camp which
is the the the recruits that are really
really strong that are able to run fast
or lift heavier weights do everything
themselves they don't think they need
the team the team organically ostracizes
them it's just a weird Quirk of social
animals right
um and the reason is is because the team
wants people on the team who will
support the team and if somebody thinks
they're better than the team the team
can't rely on them the same thing
happens for somebody who is weak and
doesn't try hard and and just keeps
falling back or quitting the team will
ostracize them as well
um because they have to learn that that
the team will take care of you but
you've got to do your part and then the
Marine Corps starts putting their
recruits in situations where you can't
do everything by yourself and so what
starts to happen is those those those
strong ones are taught humility and
learn they have to help the team and the
weaker ones are taught gratitude and
learn to to push harder and they're
welcome back into the team and so the
really interesting thing is if you
really choose to be just a part of the
team and not actually work towards the
team weirdly you'll find that the team
will organically push you to the sides
to try and teach you a lesson which is
come be a part of the team it's a weird
human Dynamic I think it's all mammals
do it
um uh because we care about the group
and everybody knows that if you support
the group you live longer
um yeah what else we got
trust with new and old players
especially when players are coming in
and out of the game so frequently good
question Reuben from Instagram asks how
do you build trust with new players uh
who are because as we know people are
constantly coming in and out of the game
well think of it like making friends
which is we're constantly meeting new
people we have our old friends with the
deepest trust
um but you know we have to be open to
new people it's okay to have a little
distance it's okay that you don't have
to trust you know you don't have to you
know share all your deepest darkest
secrets and and let them in but you want
make you want to make people feel
welcome and you want to give people the
opportunity to be a part of the team one
of the big misconceptions about
leadership and team building and all
this stuff
is that and I hear leaders say this bad
leaders say prove to me why I should
trust you no no that's not how it works
which is uh uh you have to give trust
and the leader has to earn it back and
so when somebody joins the team we're
we're the leaders right because we're
The Familiar ones so we have to give
some degree of trust and earn their
trust not the other way around we we uh
we assume we assume that they're a good
person when they come in
um so we have to take some risk for the
for the new people and and allow them to
to to to prove that the um to allow us
to prove to them that that uh
um that we will take care of them their
guard is going to be a lot higher higher
than ours because they're not part of
the team they feel you know individual
and isolated so yeah in other words be
nice
in that same in vain Paul from LinkedIn
wants to know how should I respond to
leaders who have an infinite mindset
mindset demonstrated in their policies
but have rolled out increasingly finite
measures of performance oh I love this
one Paul from LinkedIn asks how do we
respond to leaders who talk a good game
they talk about the infinite game and
the infinite mindset but more and more
of their metrics their reward structures
the incentives are finite focused in
other words short-term performance only
well then they don't really have an
infinite mindset that's the news flash
that's like companies that put you know
purpose statements on their websites and
every company seems to have a purpose
statement on their website but do they
actually make decisions based on or
advancing that purpose and you'll see
that the angel is in the details
um and so if a leader talks a good game
but doesn't act a good game then it's
just talk then it's just marketing
though no organization or leader is
perfect
a true infinite mindset is a striving
they can at least say we're trying to
figure this out or we're struggling to
figure this out we're open to ideas this
is all we know for now but we're open to
ideas at least if they did that I'd
believe them but if all of their
incentives and rewards are finite even
though they talk a big game then
um they're working counterproductively
unfortunately
again they they may in their thoughts be
trying to do it they may just not have
communicated to the team so let's not
assume let's not assume that they're bad
actors or Liars but maybe go to them and
express curiosity which is hey I'm
really interested in helping our
organization be more infinite minded
have you thought about maybe
creating new metrics to live alongside
some of the old-fashioned finite metrics
I'd love to help then see their response
that'll be a good test
Camille on Facebook wants to know what
are the practical small steps that you
Simon take each and every day to have
and keep your infinite mindset uh
Camille from Facebook asks what are the
practical steps that I personally take
to keep an infinite mindset
um there's a bunch
um uh so if we just go through it you
know I follow all the practices in that
that I wrote about so number one
Advanced adjust cause I talk obsessively
about my just cause uh inspired safe and
fulfilled uh world you heard me talk
about it today I bring it up in meetings
I never make an assumption that people
know it and even on my own team even
though our whole team knows it I will
say it all the time so I'm reinforcing
it for for the team but I'm also
reinforcing it for myself so I'm saying
it constantly as a reinforcement uh
build trusting teams which is I work
hard to to embody and practice the
things that I talk about I'm on my own
leadership journey I make mistakes I try
and be accountable and open and honest
when I make those mistakes but I'm the
first to admit that I'm assume student
I'm just a student of leadership that's
all I am there's no such thing as an
expert and I work hard every day to try
and build the teams that I know will
help advance that cause and help me be
infinite minded
um
um uh the big one which is actually the
easiest one to implement is worthy
Rivals
um I'm not trying to beat anyone I'm not
trying to outdo anyone
um um I there are other people who do
what I do I'm not trying to sell more
books than them I don't really care
um but I do admire some of them because
they do some or many things better than
me and I want to learn from them because
I'm always in a state of constant
Improvement we also believe in
partnering with some of the people that
quote unquote are our competitors we've
reached out to the CEOs of companies who
literally sell similar products as us
and we say hey can you teach us what
you're doing so we can get better at
what we're doing and we open up our
kimono and show them our product and
show them how we're doing badly and show
them how we're doing well we like like
who cares like we're we don't mind so we
sometimes do that believe it or not but
the but worthy rivalry is the easiest
easiest place to start
um and we will even talk about it in our
own team why did you go if we have a new
project we're working on we'll tell
somebody go worthy rival this in other
words find somebody who's really good at
this and let's learn from them so yeah
it is a daily practice
um and uh
um and I do work on it every day it's
like Fitness it's my infinite mindedness
infinite minded Fitness I have to work
in it every day otherwise I'll slide
back into finite mindedness which is so
tempting and so much more fun because
it's quick Thrills of dopamine right
like gambling is so much more fun than
saving money for example same idea
that was a good analogy I'm gonna use
that one again I've never used that one
before that gambling is more fun than
saving money even though saving money
will help you in hard times and that's
kind of the same finite minded is
exhilarating but it's not necessarily
good for the long term in fact it might
do damage over the long term uh in fact
I know it does
um
Katie from Tick Tock this is Tick Tock
high tech talk
um how can I bring the infinite game to
my team and turn it into an ongoing
practice Katie asks how can I bring the
infinite game to my team and make it
into an ongoing practice
um what I have found if you want to
bring new ideas to a team is start
talking about them I mean literally
um just say I heard this idea can I
share it with everybody all of my ideas
started off as conversations
um all of my ideas start off as thoughts
um going out for lunch with friends or
with teammates and I said can I let me
share an idea with you that I that I
have or that I've learned about or that
I heard
um and they all start off as
conversations and it all goes back to
the law of diffusion Katie which is
which is don't worry about converting
people find the people who are more
drawn to your to these early ideas
um so when you talk about them some
people say you're an idiot okay that's
fine we don't need to convince them and
some people say that's cool I love that
where did you learn about that I want to
learn more about that and then what
you'll start to do is you start to build
community of people around ideas but
talk about them talk about them
obsessively when I have an idea of
finding an idea I literally become
obsessed with the ideas and it's all I
talk about for a while you should have
seen me when I first wrote down the
Golden Circle I was drawing circles on
napkins everywhere everywhere I went
every meeting every dinner I had I was
doing circles and napkins it was an
obsession
um that's one of the reasons the idea
spread is because I told so many damn
people about it
um before I had any any TED Talks or
books or anything like that I was just
talking about it obsessively so talk
about your ideas obsessively
would you also like to talk about book
club I would like to talk about book
club talking about ideas obsessively so
whenever I would give
um a talk
um invariably
someone would raise their hand and say
Simon it's all fine and good what you're
talking about but our company we have no
budget for for uh leadership curriculum
right I talk about learning listening
and I talk about learning how to give
effective confrontations and difficult
conversations and all these great
leadership skills and and people would
always say we don't have the budget for
it or our company's too small
or my boss has no appetite for this and
I'd always reply with the same answer
can you afford a book
buy a book start a book club a book club
is one of the best it's a hack it's one
of the the best ways to start a
leadership curriculum without any formal
budgets or any formal learning
one of the things we've found is when
people did start book clubs is they they
sometimes got a little stuck which is
they'd be like so what'd you think of
chapter two so what we did we made a
book club
um and so you can if you visit our site
simoncinek.com if you have a little team
we built a book club that I ask the
questions we have the infinite game we
have one that's coming out on
unreasonable Hospitality coming out soon
um oh look at that things popping up on
the screen amazing
um uh oh what are we doing that oh I
didn't even know we're doing that check
it out
oh I didn't even know this I love my
team if you go to I'll read it out for
Instagram and Tick Tock it says if you
go to simonsonnik.com use the code book
club live 20 to get a 20 discount on an
infinite game book club order for the
next 48 hours uh someone who buys this
with this code will get a surprise from
me okay didn't even know that
that's awesome I love that I don't even
it's gonna be a surprise for me what the
surprise for you is I love it
um so go to simoncine.com book club live
20 to get 20 discount okay wonderful
anyway as I was saying so we made these
book clubs
um because uh they come with guided
conversations they come with guided
questions and we really offer a way for
you to go deep and have really good
conversations so
um uh yeah book club is a great way to
start a leadership uh uh Learning
Journey in your organization or with
your friends you can do all kinds of
book clubs
um I love that surprise surprise the
surprise is surprise
okay what else we got
yes Daniel M for YouTube would like to
know are the recent Mass layoffs as a
result of finite thinking or long-term
infinite minded ah so good Daniel is
asking are the recent rounds of layoffs
as a result of finite thinking or
infinite thinking and the answer is it
depends
um if the company is trying to just
balance the books finite thinking but
unfortunately what we did see in some
companies uh is they got a little too
full of themselves during covid when
some Industries and some companies were
thriving
and they started to believe that it was
them uh Peloton for example
um right place right time and their
business boomed during covid and they
thought it was because they were
geniuses
[Music]
I'm sure they're smart people
but they were right place right time and
they expanded too much too quickly and
now as the market is leveling off and
normalizing to pre-covered uh standards
uh turns out it's affecting their
business and so they unfortunately grew
too much and now they're they're they're
having layoffs to to to correct that
that that
um
lack of humility
um but a lot a lot of companies
unfortunately are also taking advantage
of it to
um
to manage to manage books so it really
the answer the simple answer is it
depends I hate to say it
um you have to look at the leadership
you have to look at the circumstances if
it's if it's existential
um sometimes it's existential like
they're literally going out of business
and they have to do it
um but if you ask me I think a lot of
companies are using it to just clean
house
which is not necessarily a good thing
but that's what they're doing
crickets
do we have any more
yes
um one here from Alan on LinkedIn which
is how do we write goals for an infinite
game
um somebody posted here Larry Jenkins
PhD can you post the 20 book club
discount information sure
uh we'll do it later Zach Zach can you
do that up Bing there it is
um it's book club live 20 is the coupon
book club live 2-0 is the coupon okay
sorry what was the question yes the
question was from Alan on LinkedIn how
do we write goals for an infinite game
how do you write goals for an infinite
game okay first of all thank you Alan
from LinkedIn how do you write goals for
an infinite game
um and so what you want is mile markers
right so infinite games you measure in
in momentum there are finite games in
the infinite game the infinite game is
not the absence of finite games so for
example if the infinite game is to be
healthy right there's many things I have
to do I have to eat right I have to
sleep right I have to nurse my personal
relationships I have to exercise there's
probably 30 things I other things I have
to do kind of do all of those things
well all the time so it's up and down
depending on where your focus is it's a
striving and you can absolutely have
finite goals within that so I want to
lose x amount of weight or I want to
gain certain amount of muscle mass or I
want to get eight hours of sleep every
day and you have your rings and your
bracelets and whatever tracking device
to measure your sleep to hold yourself
accountable to make sure you're getting
the sleep and you're practicing you're
taking magnesium and all these things so
you can have metrics but you're
measuring those metrics in order to
advance something even bigger and that's
the most important thing which is
whatever finite objectives you have
whatever finite goals you have have to
be directed towards the infinite and
very often when if we take it to an
organizational level
when you see companies who are growing
for growth's sake or I love it when
companies come to me and say we're hyper
growth and I'm like okay and show me one
article I don't care if it's Harvard
Business review or Mad Magazine like
show me one article that says that
growing fast is good there's literally
zero literature because it's not the
reason companies are pushed to grow fast
is because it's good for an investment
Community that's it and so if you're
making decisions to grow fast what's the
reason you're trying to grow fast for a
liquidity event gross right that's just
some short-termism right I have no
problem with most decisions that
companies make if I understand the
context within which those decisions are
being made and if the context sounds
like it's probably
um the logic should be easy to
understand that we need to achieve this
goal because we're trying to get there
so for example I'm a I run a for-profit
organization right and yet I'm an
idealist when it comes to our vision
it's because I understand that money is
fuel that our cause and the things that
we put out into the world that we need
money to make all those things happen I
need money for a team I need money for
reinvestment and all of the stuff that
we sometimes give away or sell on
simonsonic.com are other places are
always geared towards trying to get
towards that ideal when we have meetings
we rarely say what's good for the
company we talk about what's good for
the movement and we're constantly
reminding ourselves that the products we
make the Partnerships we make the
decisions we make have to have to tend
towards that ideal so you can have
finite goals there's no problem with
that you have to have metrics you can't
run in a marathon without mile markers
it's unnerving so metrics are good but
they have to be a measure of speed and
distance towards something bigger we
have to know the context that's that's
the interchange that's the relationship
hope that helps
last question no I want to keep going I
have fun
from Facebook would like to know how do
you balance the needs for finite lands
in the context of the infinite game
Samuel asks how do you balance the needs
for finite wins in the context of the
infinite game I think you just actually
asked and answered your own question
Samuel which is
um you have to have the infinite game in
mind goes kind of to the question I just
answered a moment ago which is there's
no problem with needing to hit finite
goals the question is to what end now
sometimes unfortunately organizations we
work for have no infinite context and
all they have are the finite goals we
have to hit every year and that's why
we're talking about this it's because
we're trying to change business we want
companies to be idealistic we want
companies to have bold Vision we want
companies to have their metrics and
their values aligned with advancing
something bigger and so that's exactly
why we do the work we do and this is why
our army exists is because we're asking
these questions of our organizations and
trying to make change ourselves because
we believe in a world that looks a
little different to the one we live in
now
the Hook's going to come out this has
been so much fun I can do this forever I
really do enjoy it thank you for joining
me on Instagram thank you for joining me
on Tick Tock thank you for joining me on
LinkedIn and YouTube and
that's it on those places and I hope
this was fun I hope this was inspiring I
hope this was
um helpful
um and
um I hope to see you again sometime soon
um and for those of you who are asking
that uh coupon is book club live 20 if
you want to use it to start a book club
I think you're all amazing love you all
thanks for joining thanks for taking
your time to be a part of this movement
take care of yourself take care of each
other